all right thank so you marry me I'm
really excited to be here last time I
was here was I think five years ago and
I wanted to take this opportunity to
kind of go over a number of projects
that I worked on in social computing
over the past few years some of it is
living edge and the last part of the
talk but a lot of it is kind of more
historical as well so I guess it's kind
of common knowledge now and a little bit
a little bit of a cliche but like really
social technologies are here and really
are part of our everyday lives from the
way we communicate with our friends and
colleagues to the way we you know gather
knowledge to even the way we politically
organized technologies that are social
social computing technologies enable and
facilitate a lot of these things and so
that's kind of the the focus of my
research for the past few years is
really to study and design and deploy
new technologies that help people
connect and collaborate and so I
emphasize the word deploy because that's
something that I've been putting a lot
of emphasis in my work where I try to
not just build something for you know
writing a publication but also to put it
out in the world have people use it and
kind of learning from how people use it
and you know iterate on that so I worked
in a variety of different settings from
you know helping children learn
programming like Michael mention to you
know peppy people helping people in the
workplace delegate tasks to you know
conversational assistants so I'll go
over a few projects in four different
categories all and more on like the more
recent work that we've been doing at
snap so I'll start with the word that I
was doing with scratch and maybe I can
tell you a bit more of a personal story
of why I got involved in this so I moved
to Boston in about 2001 after college I
went to college in Mexico where I'm from
and then I join a tech company in Boston
as a software developer so I was there
for about four years and on my year
three I said to get itchy and like you
know trying to understand trying to do
things beyond just what I was doing as a
software engineer and one of the areas
that I was really interested in
exploring is kind of how do we enable
other people like myself who I think for
me at least learning to program really
open a lot of doors even
coming to the u.s. was one of those and
how do we make that more available for
everyone and so as I looked around in
the world like trying to see who is
working in that space I found a team at
MIT who was actually working on building
tools to help people help children in
particular learn programming and so
that's kind of how I got interested in
this field and for me kind of the the
aspect of this space that I found
particularly interesting is kind of how
to take that experience of programming
beyond just like you and your computer
you and your IDE and make it into a more
social more collaborative type of
activity and you know as a sufferer
engineer that I was you know I realized
that in the real world it was very
different from how I was trained to
learn to program what I was going to
basically by myself you know in the real
world as you probably know you go to you
know Stack Overflow you google these
take snippets of code from here or there
and that's kind of what I wanted to
bring to the way people learn
programming when they're young and so as
I said you know I found the scratch team
who was starting with this project was
very early in the stages of the project
and what we were doing is essentially
build this tool that was very easy to
use for anyone I don't know how many of
us have used scratch many of you I don't
have to explain a lot about what is us
so just kind of the core ideas of
scratch is that we wanted to make
programming much easier by simply you
know representing all the computational
constructs in blocks that you can stick
together so you wouldn't make syntax
mistakes very easily and it was very
much focused on allowing people to bring
their own media like in this case you
know there was a kid who drew these cool
spaceship bring in that media into the
environment that you can then program
and manipulate so at the time scratch
was just a desktop application and
that's what I kind of found both
frustrating and also an opportunity to
explore deeper into how to make that
beyond just you and your desktop so yeah
that's actually a video I found recently
about scratch early on you can see it's
like Windows Vista I think the frame is
really old but it you know the idea is
very very simple you just drag and drop
these blocks and control something on
the screen and so what I did you know
with this was around 2005
and Flickr and I think YouTube just
started with Flickr in particular was a
big inspiration for me where you if
you're a photographer you can go to
Flickr find a large community of
photographers get comments on your
photos improve on your practice you know
learn from other people's work and
actually flickering particularly liaos
you to download photos and remix them
because you can they're all not all but
a lot of them are incredible commons
license so that's kind of what i wanted
to do but for programming and the idea
was that if you make a cool project it
shouldn't stay just on your laptop for
you to show to your friends but it
should be something that you can put out
in the world just like you do on YouTube
or Flickr and then people can interact
with it and you know you have an
audience for your creations so today the
community I just check a few days ago
has grown to about forty six million
people
it has about forty four million projects
that people have created from all over
the world one of the features that we
added early on was this idea of groups
very much like what today is Facebook
groups where people can come together on
a particular team work on things
together and you know one of the key
pieces of what we saw a very big
potential for this community to help
people learn is to support very mixing
and sure enough about 25% of all the
projects are remixes of other people's
projects let me give you an example of
what a remix is so here is a game that a
girl made very simple very modest I was
like this jumping monkey that you can
move with your keyboard but what I saw
is like this whole evolution of how that
little simple project turned into many
iterations and many other kinds of
collaborations and that's just one
example so for example in this case she
posted this project then a few days
later this other kid took that project
and then added what they call pink
slippers so this was just like a some
shoes to the monkey so that the monkey
could detect when he's touching the
black lines which is the platform or the
red the red area which is like the lava
you're supposed to avoid and so with
that technique that is this person just
changed it and and made it slightly
better much more easy to to control and
took a count score and then a few days
later this other kid said you know I
made these by adapting the shoe
technique from the previous project and
then
a whole different world like lava that
comes vertically and it was a lot more
complicated with multiple levels and so
on subsequently this other kid took that
and you can see in one of the comments
there it says you know a waste which is
the creator of the previous project I
love this game I was wondering if you
wouldn't mind me making some changes and
you can see the green project is what
they made out of that was like a much
more sophisticated like the graphics are
really cool
again multiple levels and not only that
but every single one of those dots
represents and other remix of that green
project so overall you know created this
whole kind of mini community around this
one project and like that there is like
millions of others one of the other
pieces that was really interesting is
that these two kids that the the green
project and the orange one start to
create a group and they call it a
company where they wanted to create
games together in many of these cases
they assign each other roles like
somebody may be the artist I mean
somebody may be the programmer the sound
artist etc and they created these kind
of collaborative space for them to build
games and they meant made a bunch of
games so that's kind of the norm in the
community there is many many
collaborations happening across
geographies one of the things that I
didn't show you is in scratch you can
create the project say in English
somebody can download it and see it the
code in Hebrew or Spanish or Chinese and
so allows you to like see the code in
the language that you're using which is
pretty unique for programming languages
so the other piece that I was really
interested in doing is making the
scratch community into a laboratory that
you can use for exploring all sorts of
social computing questions so as Michael
mentioned you know we study a lot of you
know how people have children in
particular perceive intellectual
property and so we often think of
children you know copying content from
others but in this case they were the
ones being copied or remixed and so we
study things like you know how people
when I receive attribution when they're
being remixed whether it's automatic or
or is you know manual and the ways this
are represented in and interpreted by
people in different ways and all sorts
of different studies that investigated
the nature of collaboration in this
particular community that can speak to
collaboration more broadly and the last
thing with is for this particular
project is that we took together we put
together a data set of five year
of activity on scratch the first five
years and published it online
Nature has a really cool Journal that
you can just publish data and so that's
what we did a data descriptor and so
since then many researchers around the
world have used it to study anything
from like how children learn programming
to like economy is looking at how like
cooperation and collaboration happens
online and so you know if there is one
thing that you can take from this
project is that this data set if you're
interested in analyzing data or using
data this could be a good source of you
know resources for you to explore and so
you know I went from you know trying to
understand how we can connect people and
enable them to collaborate for learning
new skills and then I moved to a new
space as I was you know I move away from
the Media Lab and I was looking for a
new area to explore I had been working
on scratch for six years locally I was
at MSR where you know you're given the
freedom to do kind of whatever you want
and so two things happen at around that
time I was around 2011 the first thing
that happened is that I saw a shift in
the way the technologies that we were
building things like the scratch
community would be YouTube and so on
they move away from what I saw primarily
you can have creative expression tools
so you know if you think about YouTube
the original ways people were using
YouTube or a flicker word really to
express yourself creatively and put
things out there for people to see but I
think what I saw run this time in 2011
was a shift towards the use of these
technologies to facilitate collective
action and societal impact of this is
around the time that the Arab Spring
happen right and so you know you can
argue how much you know Twitter and
Facebook had a role in the Arab Spring
but they had a role and so these cannot
really resonated with me to see like how
these things you know I was you know
playing with cute cats and you know
moving them on the screen - like you
know organizing revolutions all these
part of the same types of technologies
so that's the first thing the second
thing that happen is that as I mentioned
I grew up in Mexico where around this
time the violence in Mexico due to the
drug war was increasing significantly
and the only way for me to know what was
going on was through social technologies
through Twitter Facebook and so on
because traditional media was censored
by the drug cartels and so I found this
space is a really interesting space to
explore and to really question and train
to answer this question of you know how
can we help people connect and
collaborate to learn about the world
around and to learn about the the local
events and if you're in Egypt it may be
you know a revolution if you're in
Mexico maybe about how to avoid being
killed by the cartels but really how do
we bring people together in with this
goal of learning about the world and so
as I said you know the context in which
I started to explore this was less about
building and more about studying and
seen let's see what people already do
and then we can decide what to build and
so one of the first thing that I started
to look at is how information travel
through these social media ecosystems in
a place like Mexico where as I read out
from from this article from the
Washington Post fearing for their lives
and the safety of their families
journalists are adhering to our
near-complete news blackout under strict
orders of drug smuggling organizations
who dictate via daily telephone calls
emails and news releases what can't or
cannot be printed or air and these kind
of news blog has also extended to the
government where the article continues
and says how you know government
officials in the city of Nauvoo Laredo
which is in the border with Texas in
that city the mayor mysteriously
disappears for days and refuses to
discuss drug violence and even the
military who presides over the solders
doesn't hold any news conferences so in
mind you're in that position and you see
horrible things happening around you
from car bombs to grenade attacks and
shootings and there is really nothing in
the traditional news media so what you
see and what I start seeing remotely was
you know friends and family who lived
there telling me look at this message on
Twitter like there is this you know
report of a shooting or this report of
this violent event sometimes with photos
sometimes your steaks and a lot of them
and I'll translate these to English so
this is an example of a tweet that I
found where this anonymous woman Angela
she posted like by this supermarket
there were some risky situation and
that's the kind of term people used to
refer to all these violent events and
and so we start seeing a lot of these
can organically organize neighbors local
communities reporting what's going on in
the same way you see people here using
something like ways to avoid traffic
there you will use you know Twitter and
the particular hashtags to avoid being
killed by you know one of these
shootings that they're happy
and so I I what I did is I we had a
partnership with Twitter at the time and
so we gather data from four different
cities that were particularly affected
by the violence in Mexico for 18 months
we gather about 600,000 messages on
Twitter and trying to understand what
are the dynamics of what people are
doing there and so one thing that we did
is this is an example of one city in
particular this diagram where on the y
axis you see the number of followers
that people have each dot represents a
person on the x axis you see the number
of tweets or messages that they posted
on a particular cds hash the set of
hashtags and so among the many things
that we found is like this emergence of
these particular individuals that
opposed significant amount of content on
these communities and also have a lot of
followers in essence playing the role of
what traditional media will do and you
know if you look at what they were doing
they were essentially reading and
collating through hundreds and hundreds
of tweets I interview a number of them
they spend like ten hours a day sitting
on their computers you know analyzing
and you know browsing through this
information and posting it back to the
community and the community will find
that really valuable and sometimes
retweet sometimes ask a question like Oh
which supermarket do you mean that sort
of thing
and so I found out really really
interesting and you know one of the
other things we did was you know
analyzing as well as the repeat Network
in terms of who is the person where the
people most retweet it and sure enough
the same group of people where also you
know coming up as some of the most
widely spread people in this community
so you know we need a number of cells
are from like trying to understand how
language evolved and how people may
express come they may lose sensitivity
to the violence and through the messages
on Twitter but it was very much focused
on like understanding what people do and
so what we wanted to really do is like
how do we you know build systems that
may help or may be inspired by these
type of activities perhaps not in a very
dangerous place like Mexico I think one
experiment in a place like that but you
know maybe in a more safe space like
where we are in Seattle for example and
so we built a number of systems
experimental systems that help us curate
hyperlocal
information and by hyperlocal
information I mean things around
neighborhoods or things around even like
a few blocks in a city so one of the
things we built was a system that
essentially grabs Twitter information on
Twitter messages to create neighborhood
news reports so we deploy this
application in Seattle in particular
where you can kind of see what was going
on in your neighborhood even before
Twitter had these kind of city specific
trending topics then we also explore you
know ways of nudging contribution so we
often saw that something was happening
maybe one person posted something on
Twitter but there was not a lot of
information beyond that and we wanted to
know where exactly is this happening so
we built a system that kind of notch
people as they were tweeting and maybe
not other people who were self reporting
being at that location to gather more
information and then one other things
that we did is we also started to look
at ways to not just rely on what who
else who which people are already there
we're also sending people to locations
to help us gather information we shall
go into more detail in a second one
other thing that we did actually with a
student here at Stanford we worked on
ways of summarizing Twitter feeds from
particular events this was in the World
Cup so we just kind of were cup games in
the form of comics so like how do we
with a four-panel comic consumer eyes
what happen in a game for example and
one other thing we did was also a
application that kind of connects
commuters with one another as they
travel to tell stories and share poems
and stuff like that that one actually
was published as a Android ad that was
somewhat popular during these few years
but I'll go into more details on these
event reporting with offline crowds
because I think it provides a slightly
different angle from what the way
typically crowdsourcing is done which is
typically more focused on like you know
somebody like em Turkish or or crowd
workers on a screen and in this case we
wanted to send people out in the streets
to collect information so I'll show you
a video that describes the system
[Music]
[Applause]
so the user experience on the requestor
side was very simple we try to make it
like what is that call this is those
books will you complete just sentences
basically just say something like I
would like to use a pencil to cover the
event bla that will take place at this
time on this location and then they will
select the kind of event it will be and
based on the kind of event that they
selected we created a number of tasks
that we will post on a market place in
this case in particular it was
TaskRabbit where we will say if you show
up at this location at this time to take
a photo you know will give you a ten
dollar sony dollars whatever the idea
was that we could put together an event
report in under an hour and under
hundred dollars and kind of very quickly
create this kind of crowdsource event
reporting type of activity we deploy
these in many different eleven different
events across the US including
conference call South by Southwest in
Austin and we partnered with a number of
local bloggers who wanted to cover
certain local events that you know as we
know local newspapers are kind of
disappearing so they wanted to you know
in some ways delegate to the system the
gathering of information one of the
interesting tidbits that we learn from
interacting with the bloggers is that
they felt that the reporter our system
was creating were kind of to neutral in
some ways which was kind of surprising
to us and part of it was that a lot of
these local bloggers or local reporters
tended to have an angle that they wanted
to always pose in like introducing to
the right stories like maybe there is
some construction that is happening and
they wanted to complain about that or
some problem that the neighborhood was
having so they use our reports they
massage them that you can change them a
little bit and then they post them into
their into their local blogs and and
kind of mini newspapers that they had so
that was kind of a genre of work where
we try to kind of bring people together
both growl workers you know requesters
neighbors and also trying to understand
how people connect and collaborate out
there in the world to report on what's
happening in their local events and in
their local communities and so you know
going from like something as different
from like children learning programming
to reporting local events you know they
are all part of this kind of fabric of
technologies that basically bring people
together and achievers help us achieve
something bigger that then while back
we'll do what we can do individually so
as I mentioned as I at the time I was at
Microsoft so we built a lot of these
systems deploy them out into the world
but I always felt that you know in a any
organization where you are there are
certain constraints and certain kinds of
projects that may thrive and other kinds
that may not right just by virtue of the
environment where you are and I found a
microphone I don't know why it took me
so long they're really the projects that
will thrive are those our focus on you
know productivity Microsoft is the main
challenge is cost so for like
crowdsourcing news reporting and sending
people are into the world is caused and
as I said we try to make it under $100
but it was more expensive than that so
we were under the impression that we
were going to do like investigative
journalism or any kind of like deep
reporting it was really more like a
listicle type of article like something
that you will see on BuzzFeed like the
five things you missed at the parade or
the you know so that sort of thing and
and we were very clear when we
interacted with some of the bloggers and
so on to make sure that you know they
didn't expect like this super endeavor
thing is more like a list of facts this
happened this happened yousa follow and
so that was something that I will say
it's a limitation but we knew that
coming into that yeah I think those
would probably some of the main ones and
as I mentioned like the neutrality in
some ways we saw it as a positive thing
but in some ways the users that were
using our system felt that well I wish
you had like they angled like they
probably expected to like copy and paste
the article that we produce into their
blog the realities that they had to
massages and that's probably a
limitation
well yeah that was your dinner idea you
know we had this grand vision like oh
yeah we'll put that out there we
actually talked to folks who are in like
newsrooms and so on and they're like
yeah I could a man do something like
this I think yeah that was just we
didn't push hard enough for a lair I
mean I think we had continued working in
that space it could have happen and you
see like CNN for example had this app
called CNN i reporter which i think
happened around the same time but like I
see here and they're like more and more
interest in doing this sort of thing I
think the incentives are a key challenge
one thing that I didn't mention in some
of the events we rely both on nudging
people on social media that we're at the
event and we oh you're there do you mind
taking a photo of this or that as well
as on these paid workers and we combine
both streams of information and one of
the challenges that we saw sometimes
where one that the people who were there
at the event fell maybe like if they
knew that we were paying somebody else
fare like oh this person is paying why
am I not getting paid like why are you
taking advantage of my time and so that
was one something that we we didn't
realize how we was going to be
problematic
the other one is like some of the events
that we cover were kind of small and
local in nature so having some stranger
you know imagine a TaskRabbit maybe this
will be a fine place but like some
events may be like who is this person
and why are they here and they will
often present themselves like oh I'm
working for the startup that is doing
local event reporting and so on yeah so
we didn't mention we have a curator
online that we hire from upwork who was
a writer who essentially had an
interface where they could accept or
reject or reject with with changes like
say oh this photo is blurry can you take
another one or a you know this is this
seems you know invalid information or
something
just on a feed they will accept a reject
we had really no way to know if
something was factually true or not in
fact one of the experiments with it was
like a report on I think was like the
snow there were a bunch of snow storms
across the US and we saw that some of
the people we hired they didn't actually
go out in the streets they went online
search for like photos of snow or
something and then they like uploaded to
our system so that was a challenge that
we observed to like people cool I guess
cheat in some ways but there's better
ways to figure those things out yeah we
didn't have I mean we did have like a
mechanism to curate content yeah try to
do any qualitative yes facts yes yeah
yeah and so they all the structure of
the missions that we show workers were
very much about like collecting factual
information and the kinds of questions
we asked them and tasks were based on
the type of event that they were at so
the last project that I wanted to call
to talk about in terms of the big
deployments is this project that we
worked on a few years ago where we
wanted to figure out how to make more
efficient the connection that happens
between people by allowing them to
delegate and one thing that you probably
saw from the previous project one of the
key things that at least was inspiring
to me was this idea that you can
delegate to a system a complex task and
let the system do its thing and so we
went around and asked a bunch of office
workers in many different companies with
a survey we also the interviews where we
asked them like if they had an assistant
what will they want the assistant to
help them with so that's kind of how we
you know start to think about these this
idea in the space of you know office
workers and you know scheduling meetings
came up at the top and so part of our
idea which we were kind of naive at the
time well will solve scheduling meetings
first then we'll go down and you know
solve all the other ones we took us
three years to whom the meetings and
there is now a product that office
offers but you know I left Microsoft
after that so it's really a big big
problem
the main challenge that we wanted to
solve is something like these you
probably have experienced something like
this so you get an email and your email
notification and then you open it and
it's like somebody wants to meet with
you in this case one of our interns is
like hey you know I met at this
conference unless do you have do you
want do you want to chat about potential
internship so I was like sure so then I
go to my calendar to switch apps to go
to my calendar check potential time and
then send them an email and saying oh
yeah sure
at this time I may be available and then
they may reply oh sorry I'm not
available at that time what about this
other time and then I go back to my
calendar and like oh yeah so then I add
something in the calendar send the
invitation and done that's kind of the
easy path right we've seen all these
things go back on for four days and
that's not not ideal so part of our goal
was to you know make in situ delegation
possible and by in situ delegation I
mean the idea that you can delegate to
an assistant within the application that
you're already using in this case email
and so what we wanted to do is being
able to simply CC the assistant in this
case Cortana in an email thread and then
forget about it and let the assistant
take over all the back-and-forth and
analyzing the different kinds of time
and so on and so from the user
perspective let's say I am the one who
has access to this assistant I send an
email to this other person ruff and I
see see assistant to help us find the
time then without me involved the
assistant will send an email offering
times based on my calendar because the
assistant has access to my calendar with
natural language snow with it we want to
avoid like any kind of buttons or
anything that looked not like regular
conversation the people will have with a
human and then the person will reply
again in natural language like yeah I
mean free on Monday and so you saw that
their system for example offer a few
times in different days the person
roughly didn't have to say what time on
Monday because there was only one time
on Monday and then the assistant at the
end we'll send a calendar invitation to
everyone either to the calendar
automatically and so on that's kind of
like the magic that we were going after
and we also knew that the in-person
meetings tend to be very complex like
sometimes it's not just two people it
can be many people people inside the
same company outside the company etc and
so that's kind of the problem that we
were trying to solve and so our goal was
to build this skirling I see
that's how people you know find the time
to meet but you know there's a long
history of AI trying to solve this and
many of us have failed so why did we
think we were going to be able to do it
the other one is the language
understanding is also very difficult as
we all know and one of the things that
we thought about is that we were trying
to figure out why is that a lot of these
systems have try and fail one of them is
that there is very low tolerance for
error so as soon as the system fails
there this doesn't work you move on you
can see this with Alexa or Siri you know
you try once and then you move on if you
do some work the other one is that you
know it's a cold start problem like you
don't have enough data but like meeting
scheduling conversations Howard you're
going to solve that and how are you
going to collect this data and the last
one is that you know scheduling as I
said is really hard it also gets at the
you know cultural styles of different
organizations and people they may be
people who are like oh I don't want to
meet in the mornings and so and so that
getting all that right was really
difficult so within is that we created a
kind of Wizard of Oz type of approach
but to build a real-life system and so
we had that three-tier infrastructure
architecture for this so we started with
automation where we try to simply use
off-the-shelf and LP tools to try to
kind of parse out things like dates and
things like locations and stuff like
that but we knew that was going to fail
as we've seen with many many years so
what we had is a Tier two of escalation
so if the automatic parts detected that
it was not confident with the results
then it will escalate to non expert
crowd workers who could have these micro
tests are very well targeted towards
extracting a particular kind of
information and then they will kind of
solve that particular problem and that
data will then feed back into the NLP
system to you know become better over
time but that was not enough because we
saw that even these two systems these
two pieces had limitations like it was
limited by the kinds of workflows that
we were going to design and so what we
did is that we engage with that third
tier of macro tasks as we call them
these are expert workers typically
administrative assistants who will take
over the whole process if something in
micro didn't get resolved as we
affected and so this escalation happened
from micro to macro and the data of the
escalation was something that fed into
the system to kind of improve the
workflows over time and so that's kind
of how we started I won't go into a lot
of detail about the the kind of
automation part but we use a classifier
that essentially allow us to see the
different responses that people had to
what we call a ballot which is the
offering that the assistant sends and
then it will determine whether the
response of the individual match any of
the options in the ballot and it was
pretty accurate but you know obviously
this was flow so that's why we had the
micro tasks where essentially was a very
simple web interface that we showed to
workers where we asked them like when is
this meeting supposed to happen and then
they could have a little range of times
when when they could enter that or maybe
even things like is this even a meeting
like we are not able to detect if this
is really about a meeting and so the
goal of this test is that they were
completed in about 10 to 13 30 seconds
so very quick and short and they were
designed to collect data for automation
then the macro test that I mentioned
were triggered by the red button there
when the worker says I don't know how to
answer this it the options that you're
giving me are not enough then he will
escalate to a macro worker which had a
much more in-depth view of the whole
kind of conversation that has been going
on maybe four hours days between the
different people and then it will start
to intervene and take over and we were
collecting all this data to influence
the design of new paths in our workflow
so our workflow had like was evolving
over time like many expert systems and
the idea was to combine you know this
kind of expert system approach of
workflows with this micro tasks with
macro tesserae and as well as the more
automatic part and so I guess one of the
key things for us is that we wanted the
system to work well from day one and
this allowed us to do that because on
day zero you could mind being a hundred
percent macro you know on day ten it may
be like five percent micro and so on and
over time more and more things move from
macro to micro and from micro to
automation last time I checked I'm not
in the project anymore but like the
parent
as I mentioned as a product from office
it's called calendar help
you can sign up there it's about 75% of
the micro tasks are now are automated
and and you know some of those continue
to really continue to improve that as
well one of these that I did last night
I wanted to see how people are reacting
to the product because I don't have
access to the data anymore and so I see
tons of people's you know using the
system some people you know saying that
they've been using it for a while or
things that you know it works great for
saving times but it doesn't speak my
language which is another one of the big
main challenges that we had you know
Microsoft has offices all over yes
because the bottoms will eventually be
constrained by the workflows that you as
a designer will come up with and so
there's always exceptions and so people
really Monday I could do but I'm picking
up my kids and you know maybe I would
prefer Tuesday so a lot of that new ins
will be lost if you have buttons and the
other thing is that in general from some
of the experiments we did buttons tended
like emails that look like form people
tend to ignore them and think of spam
and there's more practical but not
really just like a research problem but
it's really like we saw that when we
introduced those things the adoption
rates were like significantly lower but
really the main idea was like all the
new ins aspects of for example we
started with all of the recruiters and
Microsoft we're using these for to
schedule meetings with people they were
not to meet and we caná-- figure out
their recruiting scenario really well
but then we said to connect with
companies outside Microsoft like
salespeople and they were having a
completely different kind of set of
constraints and requirements and so all
of that made us realize like really the
way to start and build a project a
product that can be used today is by
having this like flexible architecture
they the forms will be too constraining
for all these different solutions yeah
one thing that I have to say is that one
of the things we worry and I was talking
to Michael about this a few hours ago
about how people understood the system
from their perspective we were trying to
be very clear that the system has humans
in the loop and
you know spirally automated probably not
and so on but you know most people don't
read all these details and I notice from
this to it yesterday that some people
are like you know this is I love it yeah
I saw one tweet somewhere where people
are like oh this AI system is like
Skynet or whatever it's like so
magically works and you know we're not
even a Harvard Business Review like a
more popular press article about this in
addition to our KY paper trying to tell
people how it works because we wanted to
make sure the people understand and even
when they sign up that it is a clear
thing like oh this is humans in the loop
that's something that I still worry to
this day I mean I'm not longer involved
in the project but I I still see as a
limitation and I kind of wanted to close
on that with the limitations of you know
the the privacy implications for this
you know obviously if you're a doctor
you probably shouldn't be using this and
how to signal that in the best way the
other one is the cost of the humans in
the loop that's obviously a cost that we
had but over time that's reduces you
automate more of one of the things but
also the cost in terms of like the labor
cost and you know one of the people in
our MSR who have you know a Mary gray
has been writing a lot about like the
ethics of using crowd work and what we
should do about these things and luckily
at the time that we were working on this
project we work within the constraints
of the vendors and Microsoft approved us
to use which all of them kind of make
sure that their employees have like
vacation and they have like quit paying
salaries and so on which made our system
more expensive but also perhaps more
ethical but that's always something that
I was kind of worried about and continue
to be worried about the other one and
just more in terms of the user
experience there were two key
limitations one is about the friction
for invitees so sure I'm now delegate
into the system but now this other
person has to deal with the system back
on for like that fills in some ways
unfair and so the goal was that over
time if everyone is on the system then
the system could just look at people's
calendar and do it but that's definitely
a concern and and also one of the
reasons why some people didn't want to
use these because if you had a
salesperson for example and you want to
impress your customer you don't want to
like say oh my system will take care of
the meeting you want them to feel like
they have all your attention and the
other one is just like as much as we try
the system to be flexible
meetings are very complex and they were
definitely like when it comes to like
multiple people's in
in a meeting at some point is just
impossible like imagine trying to
organize a 20% meeting this is like
really really difficult and so we had to
like set limits on I okay we are gonna
reject those kind of requests but part
of our goal was to really think about
like the productivity space and how
scheduling was one piece in this whole
universe of the kinds of things that you
could delegate through an architecture
like this one and and kind of that's
kind of the premise that where we
started this project and what I think
this could be you know a future way in
which this can deploy it so I have a few
minutes only but I was kind of talk
about a little bit about the new
directions that we are exploring in our
lab yes always go to humans
just to like evaluate the potential
issues like that but that definitely was
a problem to within I mean in some ways
we were over cautious and at the
beginning we sent everything to humans
and we pay the extra just for that but
we felt like we wanted to have a system
that worked well and so yeah that's
definitely a challenge but I
surprisingly I didn't see that is a big
big problem most of the things that we
detected as failures were actually
failures and vice versa
so yeah yes well but within this we
primarily focus on qualitative
assessments of like we went over
conversations full conversations and try
to figure out is this an experience that
we wish we could have and then from
there like if the answer was no then we
went and see where it fell and it could
have fail in
you know the automatic part or it could
have failed more in the like our
workflow sucks in this particular
scenario or even in like the copy of the
messages that we hire writers to come up
with copy that was friendly and and also
very direct and we had a project that we
never deploy where we tried to match the
person's style so if somebody was very
direct and sure the assistant also tried
to be very direct and short and vice
versa if somebody was
more verbose we will try to match that
so we're really more focused on like the
qualitative experience for users and
trying to like reverse engineer that
based on what we saw in the system
happening yeah exactly yeah so we saw
was had a scale basically and yeah
surprisingly work well as a product that
now people can use and but again it's
expensive
so yeah so I have only a few minutes but
one of the things that we are exploring
now and again this is all within the the
view of how do we connect and people
across we using this technologies is
that you know we probably all have been
in the past few years in some ways
disappointed with the state of social
computing or social media in particular
from anything from like misinformation
to you know potential addiction problems
that people have to to social media and
so one of the things that we wanted to
explore in the in this new area of
research is how to make these
connections how to connect people in
ways that are kind of less heavy more
intimate and perhaps more authentic we
all know like sometimes on you know
social platforms people tend to present
the kind of artificial version of
themselves and that may create all sorts
of different issues or even lack of
engagement in these platforms and so
I'll go quickly here just to show one of
the things that we've been doing so kind
of part of the approach that we're
taking for kind of reimagining social
computing is to take advantage of new
platforms as a new space to kind of
redesign things from the ground up and
so new computing platforms like you know
wearables is one of those where we are
thinking of like if we were to design
tools that enable us to connect over
distance in a more authentic way
what will devices like this allow us to
do and maybe like things like you know
bio signals are available here may allow
us to do things that are different maybe
more intimate and more close so I'll
show you a video of a system that we've
been exploring that X that kind of
staying connected has never been easier
you can capture what you see share what
you think and make your voice heard but
we don't often get to share from the
heart introducing and animal uses file
signals from your SmartWatch to generate
an animal in ephemeral avatar
representing your current artery your
animal will change throughout the day
based on your heart rate you compare
animal with one special person it's like
having them on your wrist animal gives
us a whole new way to stay connected
with a simple tap on your watch your
animal will jump out and visit your
friend when they receive it they'll be
able to see it come to life then animal
will jump back to your watch you can use
animal to have an authentic and light
touch connection with that one special
person without having to take out your
phone so we've been experimenting with
the system is still very early we have a
paper that came out that you become last
month but basically the idea here is
like how to design this kind of more
lightweight experiences in this case
we're almost thinking of it more like a
mood ring meets friendship bracelet
we're really the goal is not necessarily
to be like accurate or scientific but
it's more about thinking of DC bias
beyond like self quantification and
tracking physical activity and more of a
playful way of connecting with that one
special person beyond the like chatter
that we see in all these feats and in
boxes and stuff like that and so that's
kind of still early but you know we
continue to explore this space and the
reason I mention it is because if you
are interested in this area of you know
using wearables for social connection we
are a place W can do that kind of work
the other part that we are exploring as
well is you know how to enable these
connections not just online but in the
physical world and so we've been you
know obviously inspired by things that
are creative Snap is a very company
focus on kind of creative expression and
so things like Lego bricks is one
inspiration that even from the times of
scratch I found really inspirational and
so one of the things that we're
experimenting with is the idea of using
again new platforms provide you
opportunities
is to explore things in new ways and
this case will be the idea of how do you
enable people in the same room to create
connect and collaborate to build new
things to build kind of a are sculptures
with something as simple as a mobile
phone without having to have something
expensive and I'll show you a quick
summary video it is an example of the
kinds of things that people were doing I
know you can see there yeah
unfortunately there's no plane but the
idea here is that you can take out your
phone and write right there you see kind
of you can place blocks in the physical
space and then other people can add
blocks to that as well and so you can
collaboratively leave sculptures like in
this room for example you come back
tomorrow and maybe somebody added
something or remove something and the
idea really is that you know you can do
these things across time or you can do
it in the same time at the same place
which we found that you know people
found it more enjoyable when it was at
the same time in the same place like the
two individuals or three individuals
being together there was more fun but
obviously if you wanted to be more like
productive in terms of like creating
more complex stuff being able to do it
you know whenever you want it was what's
easier so we continue to explore this
space in a variety of ways you know
trying to use AR as a form of a creative
platform for for connection and
collaboration so you know I wanted to to
close with you know giving shoutouts to
a lot of my collaborators students and
interns and and other people who are
work with us across many of these
projects and just wanted to close also
with you know if you are interested in
any of these type of spaces both AR that
is collaborative and expressive and kind
of social wearables we're hiring both
interns and full-time people as well so
with that opening two questions thank
you
I think it's really cold in Utica
medalist a five-year we're there any
follow-up yeah I've seen a lot of uptick
from people who are studying computer
science application and they're trying
to for example I recently read a paper
of a team in Europe that built a system
that analyzes programs in scratch to
detect like the paths which people are
learning different like how people
arrive to scratch and then learn
different things different computational
thinking concepts by kind of predicting
where you're going
essentially then I also seen people more
like studying collaboration like there's
a lot of people who study like
collaboration on Wikipedia or you know
systems like that and they use this data
set to study that as well so yes this is
a lot of feminists not hundreds of
papers but this may be like dozens of
papers abuses using scratch yes we've
seen that both you know they think some
introduction to computer science classes
in college are using scratch in like the
first lecture or so on but also we see a
lot of parents who you know want to sit
with their kids and they don't know
programming either but they want to
learn together and so that's another
place we when I was working on scratch
we also had a lot of companies who were
interested in automation in general and
they wanted to make automation easier
for people and so I remember we talked
to an IOT company that wanted to you
know allow people to program their like
nest like devices and using blocks place
program language so I think we've seen
the blocks based paradigm pop up in a
variety of settings so that's another
place where adults have been
I can say like oh I programmed a scratch
I mean I think it's as powerful as many
other programming languages out there I
mean obviously it has limitations but
yeah
[Music]
yeah what's on the mains a quiz on the
project the news I guess as I mentioned
you know one of the things that we saw
is that I saw her promise in this type
of work I do see a limitations in terms
of like scale and you know as I said at
the beginning of my presentation I
really tried to focus on things that can
be deployed and be used for real in real
world settings and that's always been
the intent with all the projects we
worked on doesn't always work and that
was one example where I think we try as
far as we could you know I think the
different the confluence of both
organization that you are at any given
point and the system itself you know may
not work all the time and so I think
that's one of the limitations that we
saw in terms of like what what else we
learn I think we work in a number of
price interested in news in general and
I think in some ways that was before all
these like fake news dilemma that we're
dealing with right now and I think in
light of that I feel like this type of
work is even more challenging I remember
at some point playing with the idea of
like oh what if we were to like organize
a gathering I can impromptu gathering
and I think Michael one of his students
did like this impromptu gathering in
real world and then I saw this article
about how like Russia did something like
that were like they brought like
pro-hillary and proton people in one
place they paid them and they didn't
realize that they were gonna be in
puppets and so I think in general like I
became a lot more maybe concern about
the execution of these type of things in
the real world deployment so I will so
that's the main takeaway from me like I
probably wouldn't want to do something
as large I still think there is a lot of
room for exploration and especially in
places like Mexico where I didn't even
try to do anything because I feel like
it was too dangerous I feel like still
not not there yet yeah
I do think there are certain aspects of
the language that makes it easier
sometimes make it harder but for example
there is a constant the idea of a sprite
so like a cat can be a sprite and can
have code associated with it so if you
like a project but you just like the way
say the cat moves you can download that
project and take just that piece and put
it in your project and so that makes it
a lot more modular obviously it's not as
modular as say like I know JavaScript or
something that you can build libraries
and stuff like that but we saw a lot of
kids trying to be like library like
things and some people posting projects
that the whole point was just to say oh
here is a bird flying and you can
control it with the keyword and it's
just that just for you to use it and so
that's one aspect is on the system
itself on the like language itself and
the other pieces on the social in
technologies that we built you know we
use language basic basically we use like
words that imply sharing a lot so you
know first of all every project was
downloadable you couldn't disable the
download of your project now scratch is
fully on the web so the community
becomes such a central part of the
experience that the kind of the language
and the the community is one single
thing and so that's not even easier so
let you go to every project and it's
almost like a Wikipedia article where
you can see the inside very very quickly
and so that has made it even easier to
to remix so I think I will say about the
social and the technical pieces of the
system have made it really easy to remix
that said three mixing itself was one of
the main sources of pain in the
community because moderation around like
people complaining or was somebody else
copying their work and so on became a
really big part of it and so we had to
have like an army of undergrads and hold
people like helping us with moderation
because there were things are really
easy to eliminate they're inappropriate
but there are like these tensions
between two people who are like well who
is right and like are they being mean to
each other especially kids and so I
think remixing was
both a source of tension and and and one
of the reasons we study so much around
remixing was because we were trying to
figure out how to solve that tension and
so yeah that's a lot of things to
explore there as well